Democratic governor Michigan is in hot
water after being caught hiring
Democratic link firms to lead efforts to
track the spread of corona virus and
collect health data with reaction to all
of this Senator Lindsey Graham senator
you were the one that rightly pointed
out you can't pay people more money to
stay at home and by the way to the
credit of the Pennsylvania people
they're fighting to go back to work
safely we got to do it safely right well
so let me just put this in context I
want to make sure that if you lose your
job if you're furloughed you're laid off
because some mitigation you've done
nothing wrong we want to make sure that
you receive a hundred percent of your
pay but what we don't want to do and
unemployment is to pay you more than you
actually received when you were working
contrary to what the Pennsylvania
Governor says it is not good for the
economy to pay people more not to work
than actually work and that's what we're
doing and this has become a magnet to
draw people out of the work force will
never have an economic recovery until we
fix this you should get a hundred
percent of your wages up to fifty
thousand dollars but you should never be
paid more in unemployment than your
employer pays you because that really
skews the whole economy and this guy
Pennsylvania doesn't get that I bet you
a lot of people in Pennsylvania do and I
want to ask him do you agree with AO see
that we should be excited about the
destruction of the oil and gas industry
ask the Pennsylvania governor who has a
real oil and gas supply there sitting on
top on on top of do you agree with her
ask Joe Biden hey Joe do you agree with
AO see that we should be happy to
destroy the oil and gas business in
America well I think it was a great
question now the governor whitmer of
Michigan not tomorrow we're gonna
compare the response of Florida governor
DeSantis with Michigan Governor because
she hasn't been doing so well and for a
lot of reasons because she's made a lot
of mistakes we're on two stanzas did a
lot of things right that hasn't gotten
credit for but she just awarded a
coronavirus response contract to a firm
that actually he had it said on social
media that they
Donald Trump gets coronavirus well you
can't make this stuff up right I mean at
the end of the day the desire to destroy
Donald Trump by the Democratic Party is
greater than it is to destroy the virus
in January in February they were
impeaching the president Nancy Pelosi
said on the articles of impeachment for
almost a month the trial didn't end of
February the 6th in fear to Chuck
Schumer we'd had witnesses all through
February so my Democratic colleagues
here have lost their way all I can say
is that the governor of Pennsylvania
you're wrong my friend when you say it's
good for the country to pay people more
to be unemployed than to actually work
that's not good economics and most
Americans are not looking for a pay
raise and unemployment they'd like to
get their job back well they would like
to get their job back there's never been
a medical mobilization that has been
this fast and in the end every time life
matters we believe it every light we
want to save every America we want to
cure cancer at heart disease too but
never again
I want the questions asked of every
Democrat running for Congress I want
that everyone in the media to answer did
the president make the right call as it
relates to the travel ban ten days after
the first known case in the US and did
the president do a good job building
25,000 hospital beds mobilizing and
providing a personnel mobilizing the
private sector to build ventilators and
all the shields and masks and
respirators and gowns and gloves did he
do anything good because according to
them they didn't and he really had
remembered even doctor foul she was
saying the risk is low on February 29th
you know China really seemed everybody
here yeah
you know China is the bad guy but I want
you to ask the the left do you agree
that the CDC guidelines implemented by
President Trump on march 13th saved
millions of americans from a terrible
death do you agree that declaring a
national emergency on march 13th
mobilized this country to save lives do
you agree that invoking the defense
production act really did help the
medical
la chaîne we got to bring back from
China but on February the 29th here's
what dr. pouchy said on the Today Show
you need to put this in your list of
quotes here so this is the host Saturday
so dr. pouches Saturday morning in
America people were waking up right now
with real concerns about this they want
to go to the malls to movies maybe the
gym as well should we be changing our
habits and if so how pouchy know right
now at this moment there is no need to
change anything you are doing on a
day-to-day basis right now the risk is
still low but this could change that's
on February the 29th the smartest guy in
America I trust him
his best advice was on February 29th
it's okay to go to the gym it's her okay
to go to the movie it's okay to go to
the mall so stop blaming Trump
that's what pouchy thought on February
29th and by March the 13th things did
change and when they change the
president acted he and he this guy's
saved lives throughout his career he's
been a hero we're not criticizing
yes we're making a point Chyna like
everybody yeah I got to run them